und zwar sitzt jetzt einfach mal so ein
ding hier hin und bau dir jetzt einfach
mal cool
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
mord vorstellung heute am tag nach
halloween und deswegen bin ich auch ein
bisschen ko
jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht ich
versuche euch eine coole modifikation
raus und zwar ist es die lucky blogspot
blue und mir einige von euch kennen
eventuell die lucky blogspot ansicht die
so gelbe blöcke hinzufügt die wenn man
die abbaut oder so sportlern ganz
komische zufällige dinge das hier ist
eine erweiterung davon und zwar die laki
blogs blue modifikation und zwar seht
ihr schon der einzige unterschied ist
dass die sachen blau sein es ist nämlich
nicht dass wir ziemlich eventuell denken
allerdings wurden extrem viele coole
neue sache hinzugefügt bei der lucky
blogspot in gelb war es damals so dass
nur die und die sachen spawn kommt man
nicht so eine große ausfahrt und jetzt
ist es so die teile sind blaue kannst
verändern man kann dieselbe anpassen es
gibt ganz ganz viele neue sachen
hinzugefügt werden wunsch brunnen ganz
ganz viele neue all time ist viele neue
tiere die sporen viele neue sachen und
so weiter und ich können zehn jahren
noch weiter darüber reden
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt mal so ein
kleines teil auch halo gold ein kleines
dings aufgebaut und zwar sind jetzt mal
die crafting rezepte also wenn ihr euch
wirklich fragt hey wofür brauche ich
überhaupt gold in minecraft wenn ich mir
nur kräften will kann hier einfach auf
die sonne gucken wenn ich mir sachen so
arme und so machen will dann ist es eben
nicht besser als eisen oder irgendwas
anderes deswegen gold liegt meistens in
einer kiste rum ist wegen nehmt euch
einfach euer gold paktes so um einen
spender herum mit ihm bekommt ein lucky
block dann seht ihr schon lag gleich
null also es ein neutraler blog das
heißt wenn man den setzt und abbaut kann
es sein dass etwas gutes raus kommt für
einen etwas gutes dann kann es sein dass
etwas gutes für ein selbst herauskommt
also beispielsweise 1000 diamanten in
seiner eigenen welt aber es kann auch
sein dass einfach alles explodiert
deswegen würde ich raten eure welt
vorher zu backen oder ihr macht das
ganze so in dem wir den lucky blog blog
blog blog blog
neben den einfach packt in der mitte
zweitmarke zwei diamanten
goldbarren und dann bekommt ihr einen
very lucky block der hat laut +80 das
heißt wer ist die chance schon mal viel
viel höher
dass da irgendwas cooles bei rauskommen
oder ihr macht das ganze so nimmt den
lucky blog markt ein fermentierte
spinnen auge 12 ich bin auch ein
kugelfisch und die bekommt einen
anschlag die blogger irgendwie schon
wieder normal sagt genau das gegenteil
ist wie ein lachs blog ich will mir
jetzt noch eben von den very lucky blogs
ein paar stück und von den lucky ball an
langen geraden und jetzt gehe ich mal in
den game mode 0 fall erst mal von meiner
höhe darunter und jetzt würde ich sagen
kommen jetzt auch schon zum spannenden
teilen und zwar setzt jetzt einfach mal
so ein ding hier hin und bau dir jetzt
einfach mal aber da kulbach freunde ich
liebe diese modifikation die fällt mir
einfach nie in den rücken es ist extrem
cool dass die alles hinzufügt und ich
stelle einfach direkt von seinen qualen
der verdammten wo bist du keine knete
bist ok der ist irgendwie abgehauen ich
würde sagen wir gehen einfach mal
weniger auf die andere inseln und machen
das hier weiter game mode 0 wir nehmen
einen lackierten lockt setzen hin wo ihn
ab und wir haben dann spielmodus wurde
geändert player industries flüster dir
zu
rooney hat pilz heißt die haut und er
meint ich bin in gefahr und ich soll
wegrennen
ok dann laufe ich mal die spitze steht
überhaupt denn ein spielmodus wurde
geändert ach guck mal ich wurde von bob
erschlagen der typ hat also namen
schickt dich okay ich weiß immer noch
nicht warum ich weglaufen soll wenn ich
mit diesem pilz mal anschaue doch keine
irgendwie besonderen features oder
explodiert dahin jetzt irgendwas mehrere
so kann aber vielleicht wollte mich
einfach
ich würde sagen ich geh jetzt mal eben
hier hoch und setzt hier noch mal einen
ganz normalen lucky blog bauer ihn ab
und oh mein gott verdammte kacke
wasserbeschuss sicher drei haltbarkeit
zwei bahn vier dornen 1 feder fall
dreyfus sich ein schutz drei schärfe 2,1
ich würde sagen es war echt ein lucky
block und das meine ich nämlich ganz
genau und zwar wenn ihr dann einfach ein
paar goldnuggets übrig hat mehr oder
weniger und denkt durchsuchen wofür
würde ich dir sonst ausgeben außer für
in der u oder so eine kacke macht es
niemand so ein blog macht das kann
natürlich seine dabei verreckt durch
seinen kleinen sohn
es kann aber auch sein dass sie jetzt
wie hier so einfach zehn milliarden geht
es im neuen theater die bücher bekommen
aber wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
beispielsweise einen very lucky block
setzen hin und wir bekommen ein altar
wir bekommen hier einfach eine diamant
axt mit schärfe drei waren viele
mitglieder füße drei rückstoß
plünderungen 1 haltbarkeit zwei und plus
975 andere schaden hat diallo
scharfschuss spanischer jedenfalls war
das der very lucky blog also ihr seht
schon da müsst ihr auch ein bisschen
mehr investieren wie beispielsweise noch
zwei diamanten reinpacken und zwei emmys
und ein gold aber ihr seht schon das was
hier raus gekommen ist ist es auf jeden
fall wären nehmen jetzt aber einmal
einfach mal einen an lucky block und hey
guck also ein an lucky blog muss nicht
unbedingt sein dass der gar keinen dass
den nur scheiße liefert es kann
natürlich auch sein dass ein an lucky
blog einfach auch gute sachen gibt nur
das glück dabei ist bei minus 80 das
heißt also 10% glück bei einem normalen
lucky blog ist das zu 90 prozent bei
einem normalen ganz normalen lucky blog
ist es halt 50 prozent wird also relativ
neutral
und hier haben jetzt einfach mal eine
komplette gold rüstung und eine goldene
pferde rüstung aus bekommen also kann
man auf jeden fall nicht als unglücklich
bezeichnet dann nehmen wir jetzt einfach
mal noch einen lucky botnetz mal da hin
dass laut alter ändert schlammpiste
jener schlamm junge überall sind die
möhren okay wir machen jetzt mal ganz
normal weiter mit einem lucky blog
april
wahrscheinlich wieder richtig geile
sachen am start also bisher war echt
alles richtig geld außerdem rund okay
wir setzen jetzt mal so zwei
nebeneinander
seht ihr das glück ist auch nicht mein
ganzes leben lang auf meiner seite alter
fragt man darüber mal war so 10.000
jahren tote spinnen kag aktuell partei
pasok hier bin ich gerade gestorben die
spinnen sind aber irgendwie weg aber
einen ganzen items liegen auf jeden fall
noch ihr alter her wie krank war das der
mitte mit diesen 1000 spinnen setzte
einfach noch ein lucky blog ich muss das
ist mir so die sachen man muss dabei ein
game zu null gehen und dann kann ich dir
jetzt noch abbauen und wenn ihr wissen
oder wenn ihren blog hinsetzt und ich
wollte ihn eigentlich gar nicht
einsetzen könnt ihr die nur mit einer
spitzhacke abbauen
das ist ganz komisch ok jeweils einfach
anderen dasteht break ok junge diese
dieser block mutter will mich doch
veräppeln alter jedoch ich hab' ich habe
einfach ein schwert direkt ja aber meine
absicht dahinter zu mir halten wenn ich
jetzt vorwärts machen und die aktuell
bei mir aber ist bin ich nicht okay wir
machen wir noch einen lucky blog macht
würde ich sagen diese folge verein und
bogen das gut sagte wir waren noch 1
ich habe getroffen
der ist einfach so ein riesiger gas und
auf dem gas die zeit von riesen zombie
man das ist das denn für eine kacke
alter meine ganze welt brennt ab wegen
dieser scheiß zloty blog blog klar ich
habe ihn getötet lucky blockte muss mit
retten von den ganzen anderen hier nein
nein nein verdammt verdammt verdammt er
brennt der brände brennt alter ich
glaube ich schaff's ohne alte mit den
typen zu besiegen doch ein laki blog mal
schnell hilft mir nein wieder spinnen
verdammen freunde ihr wisst glaube ich
was ich euch mit dieser modifikation
zeigen wollte es ist quasi die lucky
blogspot nur ein update und viel viel
geiler mit ganz ganz vielen neuen items
wenn ihr bock auf diese modifikation
abreise das was ich jetzt gezeigt hat
waren 62 prozent aller sachen
hinzugefügt werden mitzumachen blogs und
wenn ihr da bock drauf hat der dollar
bringen ist in der beschreibung wenn es
ihr euch gefallen hat will ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen
und wenn ihr das video erzählt bin ich
gar nicht zu hause war schon wieder auf
achse bin in deutschland aber das
interessiert doch gar nicht also tun